[Música]
los presidentes de Argentina Brasil
Paraguay y Uruguay se reunieron el
martes en Puerto iguazú en un encuentro
que tenía en el centro del debate el
acuerdo comercial entre ese bloque y la
Unión Europea que fue firmado en 2019
pero nunca fue implementado en esta cita
los mandatarios reiteraron que quieran
llevar a buen Puerto El pacto pero
dejaron Claro que tendrá que haber
modificaciones para que sea beneficioso
para estas naciones de América Latina
para analizar este tema conectamos desde
Montevideo con Magdalena base y es
experta en temas de mercosur y derecho
internacional y además profesora e
investigadora del departamento de
derecho de la Universidad de Monterrey
señor abogado bienvenida a directo a
América
muy buenos días Muchas gracias por
recibirme una vez más siempre es un
gusto estar con ustedes Bueno
puntualmente qué es lo que los líderes
del mercosur le piden a la Unión Europea
para que revise o para que se pueda
avanzar en esta implementación del
acuerdo
bien primero me gustaría
claro que el acuerdo no está firmado lo
que tenemos es un acuerdo en principio
lo que se denominan derecho un acuerdo
en principio está en una etapa de
revisión técnica que ya lleva cuatro
años más los
poco más de veinte anteriores por tanto
llevamos 25 años de negociaciones pero
el acuerdo todavía no tiene una
negociación cerrada no hay un texto
adoptado qué es lo que sucede Entonces
por qué se sigue hablando de este
acuerdo y qué faltaría para
tu firma bueno Primero que nada tenemos
el tema central aquí que es el medio
ambiente deben haber escuchado los los
oyentes de este programa deben haber
escuchado que la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula vanderlian
estuvo en algunos países de América
Latina conversando sobre diferentes
temas uno de ellos fue el acuerdo
mercosur Unión Europea y en Brasil Lula
la recibe y dice Exactamente lo mismo
que dijo ayer en la Cumbre de
presidentes del mercosur entre socios
estratégicos debe primar la confianza Al
momento de negociar y no la desconfianza
como la que tenemos ahora desconfianza
Por qué Porque normas de la Unión
Europea reglamentos de la Unión Europea
han determinado que productos que vienen
de suelos deforestados que para poder
producirse deforesta previamente no van
a poder ingresar o van a ingresar con
condiciones al mercado europeo por tanto
el punto crítico justamente es el medio
ambiente
ahora y el impacto social también que
tienen economías de países por ejemplo
como Brasil y Argentina no que viven del
sector agropecuario
Exacto alguno de los productos que se
verían afectados por esta Norma Que
vuelvo a decir que es europea no estamos
hablando de normas a nivel internacional
es una norma internacional pero
comunitaria de la Unión Europea impacta
fuera de ella en sectores como puede ser
madera cacao azúcar estamos pensando en
sectores que son claves para para estos
estados y Permíteme agregar algo esto no
significa que los miembros del
mercosurno quieran cuidar en medio
ambiente sino que requieren implementar
políticas y políticas que tengan que ver
con el desarrollo económico con el
desarrollo industrial son políticas
públicas que En definitiva son políticas
que como bien tú dices impactan en el
área social porque impactan en los
trabajadores en los campesinos en la
población afro en las mujeres como
también luego lo lo dijo Lula da Silva
que requieren un trabajo previo y no se
van a aceptar pensando en las palabras
ahora de Alberto Fernández que
justamente lo vemos en las imágenes
saludando a Lula no se van a aceptar
cuestiones que estén impuestas Y no van
a tener los miembros del mercosur Esa es
la idea central impuesto un rol un rol
de proveedor de materias primas
materias primas todavía que tengan desde
el punto de vista ambiental limitaciones
Y esta es como la la madeja que estamos
tratando de desentrañar negociarla
juntos no con disposiciones impuestas
desde la Unión Europea cuando arena un
caso puntual el del presidente de
Uruguay Luis lacalle po que se negó a
firmar la declaración pese a respaldar
las negociaciones con el bloque europeo
A qué se debe esta decisión
Bueno aquí Tendremos que analizar varios
puntos Uruguay tiene un reclamo
histórico no es de este gobierno se
viene del gobierno anteriores más
específicamente del gobierno del doctor
tabaré Vázquez
vinculado a poder negociar tener
flexibilidad a la hora de negociar
acuerdos con terceros estados o grupos
de Estados como sería el de la Unión
Europea ver si las normas jurídicas al
momento en vigencia y tal vez ahí con la
vigencia es que hay un vericueto vamos a
decirlo así jurídico hay una especie de
Laberinto jurídico al que llegara la
otra al otro extremo para saber si le
permite o no o el propio tratado de
Asunción que es el tratado constitutivo
del mercosur que establece el consenso
para la toma de todas las decisiones
y no establece excepciones si le permite
a un estado le hacen este caso Uruguay
poder negociar de manera separada del
bloque
básicamente lo que
difiere de nosotros hacemos una
comparativa de las dos declaraciones son
prácticamente idénticas las diferencias
van a estar en que se agregan temas de
restricciones no arancelarias de arancel
externo común al comienzo y luego en lo
que son las negociaciones con terceros
se hace más énfasis en el cierre de las
negociaciones con la Unión Europea y
puntualmente yo destacaría que falta una
parte final un uno o dos renglones del
primer párrafo en el cual la declaración
de los tres de Argentina Brasil y
Paraguay pone foco en la inserción en
las cadenas globales de valor
y que estos acuerdos sean un trampolín
sea en un canal para una mejor inserción
esto Uruguay lo lo retira y hace
referencia muy muy de manera muy muy
específica ha concluir el acuerdo algo
que si repasamos los discursos de los
presidentes
la calle Pou le solicita a Lula que
cierre la negociación del acuerdo
mercosur Unión Europea le dice que ya
está de esperanzado en su caso pero que
por favor cierre el acuerdo que está en
sus manos hacerlo la posición de Uruguay
vuelvo a decir
ya es histórica sin embargo nunca se
había planteado de manera tan fuerte esa
idea que si no vamos en conjunto vamos a
ir de manera individual Yo me pregunto
si si me permite tu audiencia Y si tú me
permites también en un mundo en crisis
en un mundo en el que reina la la
entropía ya no parecería ser una opción
tener una negociación de manera
individual más porque uruguaya hizo el
intento con China y quedó claro que las
intenciones de China era negociar con el
mercosur no con Uruguay de manera
individual no con uno de los miembros Y
si negociaba de manera individual era
con Brasil
Magdalena ya estamos llegando al final
de este análisis por último me gustaría
preguntarle están riesgo de morir el
mercosur si no hay un avance muy
brevemente por favor
yo creo que no creo que el mercosur es
el proyecto de integración más fuerte
para los estados de la región Y no y no
va a morir vivimos crisis tan tan
importantes como como esta lo bueno es
el diálogo y justamente estas instancias
permiten dialogar y ver las diferentes
posiciones si no se mostraran las
diferentes posiciones sí habría
posibilidad de que el mercosur llegara a
una etapa de letargo o una etapa como la
de la unasur en la en la actualidad pero
creo que no creo que todavía tenemos
mercosur y estas discusiones por muchos
años más
experta en temas de mercosur y derecho
internacional Gracias por acompañarnos
aquí en 24
gracias a ustedes y ustedes televidentes
hacemos una breve pausa ya regresamos
con más información esto es directo
América
[Música]